dès demain midi et pour quinze jours au
moins nos déplacements seront très
fortement réduit là j'ai paniqué j'ai
pris le dernier train disponible en
direction du sud pour rejoindre mon
conjoint à 8 heures deux wagons
couchettes après je suis arrivé à
toulouse où il est venu me chercher
depuis nice depuis pour essayer de
combattre mon sentiment de culpabilité
d'être parti j'essaie de télétravail et
j'ai ressorti mes vieux cours de web
d'école de journalisme pour retrouver
des outils utiles et je me suis lancé
dans l'élaboration d'un récit
chronologique coronavirus dans les
yvelines
vous pouvez d'ailleurs le retrouver sur
notre site internet alors j'ai aussi
retourné internet pour trouver des
solutions pour enregistrer des
conversations sur skype et j'ai un peu
peur seul et mon père pour tous vient
tester
[Musique]
oui oui désolé c'est moi je joue moins
désolé mais moi j'ai trouvé la solution
et j'ai finalement pu réaliser des
interviews pour aider mes collègues à
distance
sinon comme beaucoup de confiner
j'applaudis aux fenêtres à 20 heures je
fais des appels visio avec mes proches
et je mange beaucoup trop pour résumer
mon confinement belle se passe bien j'ai
plutôt de la chance et je vais faire de
mon mieux pour continuer de vous
informer
même à distance